جهود الإنقاذ جارية ولكن
هناك قلق هذا الصباح بشأن
الهزات الارتدادية خاصة مع العلم أن
البنية التحتية في المغرب لم يتم بناؤها
لمثل هذه الأنواع من الزلازل الكبيرة،
وهذا لا يعتبر منطقة زلزال في
الواقع وإحدى المشاكل هي أن
هذا الزلزال الذي وقع في الساعة 13
بعد دقائق من الساعة 11 مساءً يوم الجمعة،
كان مركز الزلزال على بعد 45 ميلاً جنوب غرب
مراكش في جبال الأطلس العالية. لقد
كنت هناك الآن هناك الكثير من
القرى النائية التقليدية للغاية وبعض
الهندسة المعمارية ليست مصممة
لمقاومة هذا النوع من هذا النوع.  بسبب
الزلزال، فكما قلت، وصل عدد القتلى
في هذه المرحلة إلى 1037 مع 721
شخصًا مصابًا بجروح خطيرة
ومن المتوقع أن تزيد هذه الأعداد مع
تسارع جهود الإنقاذ أه إحدى
المشاكل هي أنهم ببساطة ليس لديهم
ما يكفي من القوى العاملة والمعدات  للذهاب إلى
كل هذه المجتمعات النائية
في أعالي الجبال الآن وبالطبع
المشكلة هي أنه كان هناك أكثر من اثنتي
عشرة هزة ارتدادية منذ حدوث ذلك، حيث أمضى
الكثير من الناس الليل ببساطة
في الخارج خوفًا من وقوع زلزال قوي آخر
رأيناه يجلب المنازل
في الواقع، تنهار إذا استمعت إلى
بعض أو قرأت بعض روايات
الأشخاص الذين نجوا من هذا الزلزال، إنه أمر
مرعب على سبيل المثال، تمكنت شبكة سي إن إن من
الاتصال بامرأة تدعى
فاطمة تعيش في قرية نائية.
قالت إنني بالكاد أتيحت لي الفرصة
للإمساك بالأطفال والهرب قبل أن
أرى منزلي ينهار أمام
عيني، كما انهار منزل الجيران وهم
شخصان ميتان تحت
الأنقاض. الآن تحدثت معها شبكة سي إن إن
قبل بضع ساعات في  في الوقت الذي لم يصل فيه عمال الإنقاذ إلى
تلك القرية، كان هناك الآن
تدفق للمساعدات، لذلك
رأينا على سبيل المثال أن فرنسا تقوم
بتعبئة رجال الإطفاء لإرسالهم إلى
المغرب، وفتحت الإمارات العربية المتحدة
ما يسمى بجسر جوي
لإرساله.  يقول عمال الإمدادات والإنقاذ
في إسرائيل وكذلك الفلسطينيين
وتركيا إنهم
سيجمعون فريقًا يضم أكثر من 250 شخصًا
مع ألف خيمة لمحاولة المساعدة
في هذه الكارثة وحتى الجزائر التي
قطعت علاقاتها مع المغرب آخر مرة  يقول العام
إنها ستفتح الآن مجالها الجوي
للسماح بكل هذه المساعدة منذ ذلك الحين بالطيران
إلى المغرب، لكن الوقت هو جوهر الأمر.
أي شخص غطى الزلازل يعرف
أن لديك ما بين 24 إلى 48 ساعة
لإنقاذ هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين ما زالوا على قيد الحياة
تحت الأنقاض.  وبعد ذلك
يصبح الوضع أكثر صعوبة
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالعثور على ناجين في
هذه الظروف